SENATE BUDGET IN FISCAL REVIEW
COMMITTEE HEARING THAT TODAY'S
HEARING WILL HEAR FOURTEEN
BUDGET TRAILER BILLS THAT ARE
PART OF THE NINETEEN BUDGET.
I WOULD NOTE THAT WE I WOULD
KNOW THAT WILL HOLD ANOTHER
HEARING THIS COMING MONDAY TO
HEAR THE TRAILER BILLS -- THAT
ARE NOT IN TODAY'S PACKAGE.
WE DON'T YET KNOW COLLEAGUES
WHAT TIME THAT HEARING WILL BE
AS SOON AS WEDO WE'LL NOTIFY
OUR OFFICES AND IT WILL BE
POSTED.
THE TRAILER BILL THAT WE'RE
HEARING TODAY ARE THE PRODUCT OF
APPROXIMATELY SEVENTY
SUBCOMMITTEE FULL COMMITTEE AND
CONFERENCE COMMITTEE HEARINGS
AND THE MAJORITY OF THE LANGUAGE
CONTAINED WITHIN THESE BILLS HAS
BEEN POSTED.
ON THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCES
WEBSITES SINCE THE BEGINNING OF
FEBRUARY.
BEFORE WE GET STARTED.
LIKE I DID -- LATE IN THE
EVENING ON SUNDAY I WANNA POTS
FOR A MOMENT AND THANK OUR
BUDGET STAFF.
INCLUDING THE SENATE BUDGET
COMMITTEE STAFF DIRECTOR MR STEP
IN SHOCK.
LIKE TO TAKE REPUBLICAN STAFF
THE LA -- DEPARTMENT OF BUDGET
SUBCOMMITTEE CHAIR CITIES ROCK
BY CASKEY PAN DORADO AND SKINNER.
BUDGET COMMITTEE MEMBERS IN THE
CONFEREES FOR THEIR HARD WORK
AND MANY MANY HOURS OF COMMITTED
SERVE IT SERVICE TO THE
RESIDENTS OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
IT IS CLEAR THAT MANY OF YOU
HAVE WORKED MANY OUR STATE
COUNTLESS HOURS INTO THE NIGHT
TO COMPLETE THE NECESSARY WORK
TO GET US TO THIS PLACE.
AND THERE'S MILES TO GO BEFORE
YOU REST AS THE POEM FAMOUSLY
STATED -- WE ARE AWARE OF THAT
AND WE APPRECIATE YOUR HELP.
I'D LIKE TO OFFER MY VICE CHAIR --
ANY COMMENTS HE MAY HAVE BEFORE
WE GET STARTED.
MADAM CHAIR THANK YOU FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP AND THE STAFF
LEADERSHIP.
STORE JUST THROUGH THESE MANY
MONTHS.
OF LABORIOUS HEARINGS AND
DELIBERATIONS AND CONSIDERATIONS
AND STUDY.
THE HOPE IS THAT WE COME OUT
WITH A BUDGET THAT'S GOOD FOR
THE PEOPLE OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA NOT JUST FOR THE NEXT
TWO YEARS BUT FOR THE LONG TERM.
THAT IS OUR GOAL AND AND IT'S
BEEN A PLEASURE WORKING WITH ALL
OF YOU AND WE'VE STILL GOT SOME
WORK AT AHEAD OF US.
THAT WE DO SENATOR AND LET'S
BEGIN BY HAVING THE ROOM A
QUORUM ESTABLISH WOULD YOU
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL MITCHELL.
SEND YOUR WELL -- ALSO.
WE'RE TAUGHT OF JONES.
LEYVA.
MCGUIRE.
MONNING YEAR MORE LOCK
[inaudible]
MORRELL [inaudible]
PAN [inaudible]
ROTH [inaudible]
SKINNER [inaudible]
STERN [inaudible]
STONE.
NUMBER.
WHY BECAUSE HE?
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF A QUORUM
HAS BEEN NOTED.
MR THIS ONE OFTEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON THANK YOU SO MUCH
LET'S GO AHEAD AND GET STARTED
COLLEAGUES WITH OF THE FIRST
ITEM MARKED ON OUR AGENDA AB.
SEVENTY SIX EDUCATION FINANCE.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR. TO FOR
THIS FIRST BILL AB SEVENTY SIX
AND I'LL CLARIFY THE START THAT
IN EACH OF THESE TRAILER BILLS
THERE ARE A NUMBER OF DETAILS
SOME OF THEM ARE VERY LONG.
SO FOR EACH OF THEM ALL MENTION
TWO OR THREE OF WHAT WE FINANCE
CONSIDER SOME THE MOST IMPORTANT
PROVISIONS OF IT AND HAPPY TO
TAKE QUESTIONS ABOUT ANY OF THE
ITEMS I THINK THAT'S MOST
APPROPRIATE THANK YOU.
SO IN THIS BILL -- THREE THE KEY
PROVISIONS THAT WE WANT TO
HIGHLIGHT OUR FIRST
APPROPRIATING SEVERAL HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS IN PROPOSITION
NINETY EIGHT SAID ABOUT FUNDING
THIS IS FUNDING OWED UNDER
PROPOSITION I HIGHER FISCAL
YEARS SO THAT'S MONEY THAT WILL
GO DIRECTLY TO K. FOURTEEN
EDUCATION.
A SECOND HIGHLIGHT OF THIS BILL
IS A CHANGE TO THE PROPOSITION
NINETY CERTIFICATION PROCESS.
REQUIRING THAT THERE BE NO
DOWNWARD ADJUSTMENT TO PROPER TO
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT AT THE
END OF THE FISCAL YEAR FOR PRIOR
YEARS IT CAN GO UP OR IF WE DO
OWE MORE MONEY TO SCHOOLS BUT AT
THE END OF THE FISCAL YEAR.
CANNOT GO DOWN AND IT ALSO
ELIMINATES THAT COT ALLOCATION
SCHEDULE THAT WAS CREATED IN THE
PREVIOUS BUDGET ACT THAT
PREVIOUSLY WOULD USE ACCESS
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
APPROPRIATIONS FOR SATELLITE
PAYMENTS IN.
FUTURE BUDGETS.
AND THEN THE THIRD ITEM THAT I
WANT TO HIGHLIGHT FOR THIS BILL
IS AN ADJUSTMENT IN THAT COST OF
LIVING ADJUSTMENT COLA FOR THE
LCS FAST -- WHICH IS
CONTINUOUSLY APPROPRIATED UNDER
LAW -- BUT WHEN COAL -- FOR LCF
EXCEEDS THE OVERALL GROWTH IN
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT THERE
WOULD BE AN ADJUSTMENT TO THAT
CALL LEVEL UNDER THIS BILL SO
HAPPY TO TAKE ANY QUESTIONS
ABOUT IT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH QUESTIONS
[inaudible]
MR MORLOCK.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR I JUST.
WOULD LIKE A LITTLE MORE
ELABORATION AS TO THE
PROHIBITION OF OF NO DOWNWARD
ADJUSTMENTS FOR PROP NINETY
EIGHT IN THE FUTURE WE KIND OF
INCOME BRING [inaudible]
FUTURE.
PLAYED.
LAKE JURORS -- IN AN ECONOMIC
DOWNTURN IN.
WHAT KIND OF IMPACT WOULD THAT
HAVE ON THE GENERAL FUND BECAUSE
IN THE GENERAL FUND WERE PAYING?
FOR SCHOOL BOND PAYMENTS.
SO IT WOULD PROBABLY PUT AN EVER
MORE STRESS I WOULD THINK ON THE
GENERAL FUND SO I'M I'M JUST
TRYING.
TO UNDERSTAND THE LOGIC.
SO I'LL MAKE A COUPLE POINTS IN
AND JUST GIVE MY TEAM CAN
ELABORATE AS WELL I THINK THE
FIRST THING IN TERMS OF GENERAL
ENCUMBRANCE ON FUTURE.
LEGISLATURE'S ALL OF THIS IS IN
STATUTES SO -- SO ANYTHING --
FUTURE LEGISLATURE CAN TAKE ANY
ACTION ON ANY OF THE ITEMS IN
THIS BILL OR IN CURRENT LAW.
IN THE PAST YES -- AND SO AND SO
THAT'S THE FIRST BROADER POINT --
I THINK SECOND -- WELL -- THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND
ADMINISTRATION REALIZES FOR
SCHOOLS IT CAN BE VERY TOUGH
WHEN THEY'VE GONE THROUGH A
FISCAL YEAR THEY BELIEVE THAT
THIS IS THE MONEY THAT THEY ARE
ENTITLED TO UNDER PROPOSITION.
NINETY EIGHT AND THEN AFTER THAT
YEAR IS OVER -- IT ACTUALLY
TURNS OUT UNDER PROPOSITION
NINETY EIGHT THEY WERE SUPPOSED
TO SPEND LESS THAN THAT AND AND
THAT CHANGES WHAT THEY GET IN
FUTURE YEARS EVEN THOUGH THAT IS
THE GUARANTEE WHAT THEY'RE
SUPPOSED TO RECEIVE IN FUTURE
YEARS.
SO WE SEE THIS AS GIVING SCHOOLS
MUCH MORE PREDICTABILITY -- THAT
WE SHOULD HAVE UNDER PROPOSITION
NINETY EIGHT WE ALL KNOW IT'S A
VERY COMPLICATED FORMULA BUT
ONCE THE FISCAL YEAR IS OVER WE
BELIEVE THAT THE LEVEL OF THAT
SHOULD BE WHAT THEY'RE ENTITLED.
TO AND THEN THE LAST THING IN
TERMS OF FISCAL PRESSURE THAT
YOU MENTION SENATOR MORE LOCK --
THE LAST CHANGE THAT I MENTIONED
IN TERMS OF ADJUSTMENTS TO THE
COAL LOT.
THAT'S DESIGNED TO ADDRESS IN
MANY WAYS THE CONCERN THAT YOU
RAISED IN THAT WHAT IF YOU HAVE
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT THAT'S
GROWING AT A LEVEL THAT'S MAYBE
LESS THAN WE ANTICIPATED.
AND YET THE COLA THAT WE HAVE IN
STATUTE WHICH IS CONTINUOUSLY
APPROPRIATED IS MUCH HIGHER.
THAN WE MIGHT HAVE A PROBLEM
WITH PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT OR
EIGHT MY CROWD OUT YOU KNOW THE
LCS OUT FUNDING MY CRIED OUT
OTHER PROGRAMS WITHIN THE
GUARANTEE AND WE'VE BEEN HAVING
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT SOME OF
THOSE OTHER PROGRAMS IN
CONFERENCE COMMITTEE IN BUDGET
COMMITTEE WHETHER IT'S SPECIAL
EDUCATION FUNDING.
OR AFTER SCHOOL FUNDING OR OTHER
PROGRAMS SO THIS CHANGE IT
REDUCES THAT PRESSURE BY
ALIGNING THE COLA WITH GROWTH IN
THE GUARANTEE IF THE GROWTH IN
THE GUARANTEES LOWER THAN
ANTICIPATED.
THANK YOU THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
YOU'RE VERY WELCOME SIR TO
NIELSEN.
YOU. TO SPECULATE ON THE IMPACT
ON DECLINING BOTH DISTRICTS OF
THIS.
THIS ISSUE SOMEWHAT CONCERNED
BUT MAYBE NOT ENOUGH TO GIVE ME
A NO VOTE ON IT BUT IT DOES
CONCERN ME THE I DON'T KNOW I
WANNA SEE TAMPERING BUT THE
TWEAKING OF FOR THE PROP NINETY
EIGHT FORMULA. ONE LET BE.
TO SCHOOLS WHOSE.
THANK ENROLLMENT.
SO I'LL MAKE ONE POINT AND THEN
A JESSICA CAN ELABORATE I THINK
THE MAIN THING HERE IS THAT.
BY OFFERING GREATER
PREDICTABILITY AND CERTAINTY FOR
PRIOR YEAR APPROPRIATIONS.
GIVE THOSE SCHOOLS MORE
STABILITY US TODAY AT THE TIME
IF THEIR ENROLLMENTS ARE
DECLINING.
THEY'RE NOT ALREADY ALLOW
ALREADY TO DEALING WITH THAT
THEY'RE NOT ALSO DEALING WITH
FLUCTUATIONS IN THE GUARANTEE.
AND THE OVERALL POINT THOUGH IS
THAT WITH DECLINING ENROLLMENT --
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT FUNDING
TO SCHOOLS GENERALLY BASED ON
EIGHTY EIGHT THAT IS SOMETHING
THAT A LOT OF SCHOOLS ARE
MANAGING AND JESSICA.
I WOULD JUST NOTE THAT THERE IS
I'M SORRY JUST COMES DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE I WOULD JUST NEED A
COUPLE OF THINGS FIRST THAT
WITHIN THE PROPOSITION NINETY
EIGHT GUARANTEE NOT ALL OF THE
TESTS.
ON THE THE TEST ONE TEST TO TEST
THREE THATWE FIND THAT ARE ADA
DRIVEN SO CURRENTLY BECAUSE WE
ARE IN A DECLINING ENROLLMENT
ENVIRONMENT WE ARE IN A TEST.
ONE AND THAT ENSURES THAT EVEN
IF.
THE ADA DECLINED SIGNIFICANTLY
WE'RE STILL RECEIVING THAT
APPROXIMATELY 40% -- OF THE
STATE BUDGET THAT WAS GUARANTEED
WITHIN PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
ON THAT DATES BACK -- TO
NINETEEN EIGHTY SIX EIGHTY SEVEN
AND SO THAT'S THAT IS ONE LEVEL
OF PROTECTION I WOULD ALSO JUST
REMIND FOLKS THAT -- WHEN IT
COMES TO THE LCF APPORTION IT
WITHIN THE PROPOSITION NINETY
EIGHT GUARANTEE -- THERE IS A A
HOLD HARMLESS ESSENTIALLY SO
SCHOOL DISTRICTS CAN USE THE
EIGHTY FROM THE PRIOR YEAR IF IT
WAS HIGHER TO MAINTAIN FUNDING --
IN THEIR CURRENT YEAR SO THERE
ARE SOME MECHANISMS IN THERE TO
PROTECT THOSE SCHOOLS -- FROM
FUNDING DECLINES THANKS FOR
REMINDING ME THAT LOCAL.
CONTROL FUNDING FORMULA
PROVISION.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS FOR MEMBERS.
SEE NONLOCAL UP TO PUBLIC
COMMENT.
GOOD AFTERNOON JENNIFER BAKER
WITH THE CALIFORNIA TEACHERS
ASSOCIATION WOULD LIKE TO THANK
YOU AND AND THE STAFF FOR ALL
THE HARD WORK DAY DONE W
APPRECIATE THE FACT THAT WE'D
HAVE AN EIGHTY ONE POINT ONE
BILLION DOLLAR PROP NINETY EIGHT
PACKAGE.
WE WOULD ENCOURAGE YOU TO ENSURE
THAT ANY TASK AND FOR MANY OR
SIMILAR PACKAGE TO ASSURE THAT
WE CAN KEEP THOSE LEVELS MOVES
FORWARD TO THAT WE CAN MAKE SURE
THAT OUR STUDENTS ARE FULLY
SUPPORTED THANK YOU THANK YOU
NEXT WITNESS.
THE COURT ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA TAX REFORM
ASSOCIATION WITH AFFILIATE
MYSELF WITH THE COMMENTS OF OUR
BOARD MEMBER THE CTA THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANY FURTHER COMMENTS.
ALL RIGHT SEE NONE PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL.
AB SEVENTY SIX THE MOTION IS TO
PASS MITCHELL.
FIVE I NIELSEN HI FEELS AND I
FELL.
WELL I'D ARE ALSO THEY'RE ALSO
ALL RIGHT OR TITLE.
I JONES JONES I LEYVA THEY'VE
AYE MCGUIRE.
MCGUIRE AYE MONNING.
MONEY ON A MORE LOCK
[inaudible]
MORRELL.
PAN HI CAN I ROTH.
ROTH AYE SKINNER SKINNER AYE
STERN.
STONE STONE I AMBER.
AMBER I WAY KASKI.
BECAUSE HE HI.
I APPRECIATE THAT.
THIS IS THE EIGHTEEN NOT
TYPICALLY SCHEDULED HEARING WE
HAVE MEMBERS AND OTHER PLACES
BUT I'M NOT GOING TO HOLD THE
ROLE OPEN I'M JUST GOING TO
CLOSE IT DOWN IF WE HAVE ENOUGH
TO CLOSE AN ITEM.
MEMBERS WILL HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO VOTE ON THE
STREET BILLS ON THE FLOOR
SUGGESTS.
SENATE INTO THE RECORD IF THERE
ARE -- MEMBERS WHO ARE HERE THAT --
DESPERATELY WANT TO BE ADDED ON
THEY SHOULD HAVE THEIR STAFF
CALL THE SERGEANTS AS SOON AS
POSSIBLE WITH THAT THE VOTE.
IN ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES.
MOVING ON TO AB SEVENTY SEVEN
HIGHER EDUCATION.
SO ON THE HIGHER EDUCATION
TRAILER BILL I'LL MENTION FOR
HIGHLIGHTS.
THE FIRST IS A NEW PROGRAM -- OF
CAL GRANTS FOR STUDENTS WITH
DEPENDENT CHILDREN THAT IS
STUDENT PARENTS -- PROVIDING
THEM UP TO SIX THOUSAND DOLLARS
IN GRANTS TO SUPPORT THEIR
EDUCATION AS PART OF A TWO
GENERATION APPROACH.
A SECOND IN CONVERSATIONS WITH
THE LEGISLATURE -- AGREEING ON
AN APPROACH WHERE WE
DRAMATICALLY INCREASE THE NUMBER
OF COMPETITIVE CAL GRANTS BY
MORE THAN 50% -- SO THEY WOULD
GO FROM A LITTLE OVER TWENTY
FIVE THOUSAND CAL GRANTS TO
FORTY ONE THOUSAND AWARDS -- FOR
THESE COMPETITIVE AWARDS AND WE
WOULD ALSO MAKE THE CHANGE THAT
STUDENTS UNDER AB FIVE FORTY
UNDOCUMENTED STUDENTS ARE
ELIGIBLE FOR THESE COMPETITIVE
AWARDS -- THE THIRD HIGHLIGHT IS
THE ADDITION OF A SECOND YEAR US
FREE QUICK COMMUNITY COLLEGE
TUITION FOR FIRST TIME FULL TIME
STUDENTS -- AND AS WELL AS SOME --
CLARIFICATION OF THE FUNDING
FORMULA FOR CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGES AND FINALLY -- THE
CREATION OF A CHILD SAVINGS
ACCOUNT GRANT PROGRAM A FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS AND HAPPY TO
TAKE ANY QUESTIONS [inaudible]
YEAH
[inaudible] FIVE FOUR IN
[inaudible]
YEAH [inaudible]
WHATEVER.
YEAH YEAH THANK YOU ARE
QUESTIONS COLLEAGUES
[inaudible]
QUESTIONS [inaudible]
THE BILL [inaudible] THIRTY
NIELSEN.
I PROBABLY OKAY ON THIS BUT I
MUST.
CONFESS A LITTLE CONCERNED ABOUT
THE STUDENT AID GRANTS THE
UNDOCUMENTED.
THAT WILL COME UP LATER AGAIN
AND I'LL PROBABLY HAVE MORE
CONCERNS ABOUT IT IN OTHER
SECTIONS OF THE BUDGET.
THANK YOU FOR THE QUESTION.
SEEING NONE PUBLIC COMMENT.
SEE NONE THE BILL HAS BEEN MOVED
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
AB SEVENTY SEVEN THE MOTION IS
TO PASS MITCHELL.
MITCHELL AYE NIELSEN NIELSEN AYE
BELL BILL EITHER ALSO.
OR TITLE.
OR TELL I JONES.
JONES NO LABOR LEYVA AYE MCGUIRE
MCGUIRE AYE MONNING MONEY I'M
MORE LOCK.
MORE LIKE HIGH MORALE.
PAN HI CAN I ROTH.
ROTH AYE SKINNER SKINNER ONLINE
STERN STERN AYE STONE.
STONE NO I'M BURKE.
NUMBER I BY KASKI ACOSTA HI --
ALSO HI. FIFTEEN TO TO THE
MEASURE KERRY'S -- ITEM NUMBER
THREE A. B. EIGHTY TWO GENERAL
GOVERNMENT.
FINANCES.
SIGN GENERAL GOVERNMENT ALL
MENTION FOR ITEMS OF NOTE THE
FIRST IS AN INCREASE IN THE
SAFETY NET RESERVE WHICH IS
CURRENTLY AT TWO HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS THIS BILL WOULD
AUTHORIZE THE TRANSFER OF AN
ADDITIONAL SEVEN HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS.
BRING THE BALANCE TO NINE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS AND
SIXTEEN IN PARTICULAR DESIGNED
IN A RECESSION TO PROTECT OUR
MEDI CAL AND CAL WORKS PROGRAMS.
THE SECOND IS THE CREATION OF
THE OFFICE OF DIGITAL INNOVATION
WITHIN THE GOV OPS GOVERNMENT
OPERATIONS AGENCY AS WELL AS THE
DIGITAL INNOVATION SERVICES
REVOLVING FUND.
A THIRD ITEM THEY SUPPORT TO
COUNTIES -- TO UPDATE THEIR
VOTING SYSTEMS AS WE ENTER AT
CRITICAL ELECTION YEAR - BOND
BUT THE STATE AND FEDERAL LEVELS --
AND THEN FINALLY -- AND OWN
CONVERSATIONS WITH MANY OF YOU
DISPOSITION OF THE CINEMA
DEVELOPMENTAL CENTER PROPERTY --
ARE ALL IN THIS TRAILER BILL.
THANK YOU QUESTIONS MEMBERS
[inaudible] THIRTY NIELSEN.
GENERALLY I THINK WE'VE GOT A
LOT OF POSITIVE.
ELEMENTS HERE.
I TAKE THE LIKE THE YOU GET
REQUIREMENTS RELATED TO FISCALE
THAT'S CERTAINLY BEEN A PROBLEM
THEN I THINK IT'S GOING TO
CONTINUE TO BE A PROBLEM.
SO THE FIRST CAL A PORTION OF
THIS IS VERY MUCH TO MY
SATISFACTION [inaudible]
THE THE SERVICE FEES FOR THE
BEVERAGE.
THAT.
SEEMS TO BE SOMETHING A. B. C.
DOES.
MORE AT THE ONE AREA THAT WAS A
LITTLE BIT FROM PROVOKING I
THINK WAS C. SOUR.
SEE COMMISSIONER TEAR -- WE
DISCUSSED IT THE OTHER NIGHT.
AND THAT'S TO ME PRETTY BAD
OPTICS.
BUT IT MAY NOT BE ENOUGH TO
WARRANT A NO VOTE.
BUT DID.
IT'S OF SOME CONCERN.
AND IF IT THE LITTLE BIT OF
TAMPERING WITH THE CAL WORKS
WHICH WAS ORIGINALLY THE GAIN
PROGRAM -- RICK RELATED TO THE
THE DAY SINGLE SAFETY NET
RESERVE PROGRAM.
AND THE WORKING REQUIREMENTS.
AGAIN I DON'T THINK THAT'S A
FATAL FLAW TO THE BILL.
BUT JUST TO POINT OUT THAT THERE
ARE SOME CONCERNS.
THANK YOU IN AND JUST TO CLARIFY
AS WE WERE ABLE TO CLEAR FIVE
SAID THE NIGHT AT THE CONFERENCE
COMMITTEE.
THE ACTION WITH REGARD TO THE
SALARY DOESN'T APPLY TO THE CITY
IN THE PRESIDENT.
BUT IT LISTS THE CEILING --
SIMPLY FOR CONSIDERATION DOESN'T
AUTOMATICALLY DICTATE THAT THE
SELLER WILL BE ADJUSTED BUT IT
RAISES THE CEILING. FOR PERSONAL
PURPOSES AS NAY -- GO OUT --
INTO SEARCH SEARCH FOR FUTURE
PRESIDENT.
ANY FURTHER QUESTIONS MEMBERS.
I'M PUBLIC COMMENT.
I'LL ENTERTAIN A MOTION THE BILL
THANK YOU IT'S BEEN MOVED PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL AB AT TO THE
MOTION IS TO PASS MITCHELL.
HI I NIELSEN AYE AYE NIELSEN AYE
BILL.
BILL UTTER ALSO DRAW SO I OR TO
OTHER.
THE OTHER SIDE JONES.
JONES NEW LABOR.
LEYVA AYE MCGUIRE BUT WHERE I
MONEY.
MONEY NINE MORE LOCK MORE LOOK I
AM MORALE.
BROWN THOUGH PAN HI I'M ROTH.
ROTH AYE SKINNER SKINNER AYE
STERN.
STERN AYE STONE STONE NO NUMBER.
WHY BECAUSE HE?
WHY BECAUSE THE AYE?
WITH A VOTE OF FOURTEEN TO THREE
THE MEASURE KERRY'S ITEM FOR
EMPLOYMENT [inaudible]
FINANCE. THREE ITEMS IN THIS
BILL -- WANTED TO NOTE -- THE
FIRST IS THE EXTENSION OF PAID
FAMILY LEAVE FROM SIX WEEKS TO
EIGHT WEEKS BEGINNING JULY FIRST
OF NEXT YEAR.
AND THIS IS ACCOMPLISHED BY
REDUCING THE RESERVE REQUIREMENT
IN THE FIND SUPPORTING PAID
FAMILY LEAVE FROM 45%.
PERCENT AND THE ADMINISTRATION
IS IN THE PROCESS OF STARTING UP
A TASK FORCE TO PUT TOGETHER
MORE DETAILS ON WHERE TO GO FROM
HERE BY THIS FALL -- THE SECOND --
AND RELATED TO THAT I SHOULD
ALSO MENTION NOT PAID FAMILY
LEAVE THAT OUT THIS BILL ALSO
INCLUDES - IT EXCLUDED
EMPLOYEES IN GOVERNMENT WHO ARE
ON ENHANCE AND THE ICE FOR THEM
TO HAVE ACCESS TO PAID FAMILY
LEAVE AS WELL.
THE SECOND ITEM OF NOTE IN THIS
BILL IS THE REVERSAL OF THE
PAYROLL DEFERRAL WHERE PAYMENTS
ON JUNE THIRTIETH AT FOR OF
STATE PAYROLL WERE WENT TO JULY
FIRST INTO THE NEXT FISCAL YEAR.
THIS IS PART OF PAYING DOWN THE
WALL OF DEBT AND FINALLY THIS
BILL INCLUDES SOME
ADMINISTRATIVE CHANGES TO THE
CAL SURVEYS CAL SAVERS PROGRAM
FORMERLY SECURE CHOICE WHICH IS
IN THE PROCESS OF WRAPPING UP.
THANK YOU QUESTIONS MEMBERS.
THIRTY NIELSEN FOLLOWED BY
SENATOR STONE.
CONCERN I HAVE HERE IS -- UNPAID
FAMILY LEAVE.
MAYBE NOT AS MUCH AS WHERE WE'RE
AT TODAY BUT WHERE THIS IS
HEADED.
AND THAT IS OF CONCERN AND OF
SUFFICIENT CONCERN TO DISPOSE ME
TO BE A NO VOTE.
PLUS SOME OF THE PROVISIONS IN
HERE ARE -- A LITTLE.
I THINK A DECKS TACKING RELATED.
TO COLLECTIVE BARGAINING
[inaudible]
TOP.
I THANK YOU MA'AM TERMS KIND OF
PIGGY BACK ON MY CONCERN ABOUT
THE PAID FAMILY LEAVE I THINK
IT'S GREAT THAT WORKS TO
EXTENDING IT FROM SIX WEEKS TO
TWO EIGHT WEEKS BUT THAT'S GOING
TO COME WITH THE COMMENSURATE --
PAYROLL DEDUCTION AN STI -- DO
YOU HAVE AN ESTIMATE AS TO WHAT
PERCENTAGE OF AN INCREASE THAT
ARE.
WORKING CLASS CONCEDE THEIR STI
DEDUCTIONS COMING OUT OF THEIR
PAYCHECK AFTER THAT RESERVE IS
EXHAUSTED.
THE FREDDIE -- WE'VE DESIGNED
THIS PROPOSAL FOR THE IMPACT TO
BE MINIMAL BUT I WILL TURN IT
OVER TO MY COLLEAGUE FOR THE
CAPTAIN IN THE DANIEL BRAND WITH
APARTMENT A FINANCE -- ACTUALLY
WITH THE RATE IS GOING TO BE
STABLE FOR TWENTY TWENTY UNDER
THIS PROPOSAL -- WITHOUT THE
PROPOSAL WOULD HAVE INCREASED
ONE TENTH OF A PERCENT AND WERE
ABLE TO HOLD STABLE FOR THE FOR
TWENTY TWENTY ONE AS WELL.
OKAY THAT'S BECAUSE YOU'RE GONNA
BE UTILIZING RESERVES.
TO TAPPED FOR A RESTART GOING TO
THE CITIZENS FOR THEM TO
CONTRIBUTE CRACKED.
IF THEY IT BALANCES OUT -- WE DO
EXPECT AN INCREASE IN TWENTY
TWENTY TWO AND THAT'S ONE TENTH
OF A PERCENT AGAIN I'M GONNA
JUST EXPRESSED MY CONCERNS I
HAVE A LARGE -- WORKING CLASS
AND IN RIVERSIDE COUNTY -- THESE.
WITH WITH DRAWS OUT OF THEIR
PAYCHECKS ARE VERY REGRESSIVE --
I'D I SOMETIMES JUST DON'T
UNDERSTAND WHY WE DON'T GO AFTER
THE MORE AFFLUENT. TO SUBSIDIZE
THIS INSTEAD OF GOING AFTER THE
PEOPLE THAT ARE HAVING TROUBLE
PAYING FOR THE HIGH GAS PRICES
THAT THEY'RE PAYING FOR RIGHT
NOW THE HIGH.
HOUSING PRICES THAT ARE PAYING
NOW AND WE HAVE A SIGNIFICANT
HOMELESS PROBLEM IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THE LARGEST IN THE
COUNTRY.
AND IT'S THESE LITTLE.
LITTLE HEAD PSYCHOLOGY DEATH BY
A THOUSAND SLICES.
THAT IS GOING TO HAVE ITS TOLL
ON OUR ARE WORKING AND MIDDLE
CLASS IN CALIFORNIA AND I
REQUEST FOR THOSE REASONS I
CAN'T SUPPORT THE BILL.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS.
SEE NONE PUBLIC COMMENT.
THE BILLS WOULD MOVE PLEASE ALL
THE ROLL AB EIGHTY THREE THE
MOTION IS TO PASS MITCHELL HI
ALL I NIELSEN.
NIELSEN HI BILL WELL I ALSO PUT
OTHER JONES JONES NO LEYVA.
MCGUIRE.
MCGUIRE AYE MONNING.
MORE LOOK MORE LIKE NO MORALE.
MORRELL NO PAN.
ROTH.
I SKINNER SKINNER ONLINE STERN
[inaudible]
STONE.
I'M BURKE NUMBER I WHY BECAUSE
HE BECAUSE THE HI YES AND I'D
ENOUGH.
IT DOESN'T I DON'T KNOW.
WITH ALL THAT OPEN.
THE VOTE OF SEVENTY FIVE WE WILL
HAVE TO HOLD IT OPEN TO SOME OF
OUR COLLEAGUES RETURNED FROM.
ESTABLISHING A QUORUM HEALTH
COMMITTEE MOVING ON TO ITEM FIVE
POLITICAL REFORM ACT OF NINETEEN
SEVENTY FOUR ONLINE FILING
SYSTEM FINANCE.
SO ONE MAJOR ITEM THIS BILL THIS
IS REGARDING THE UPDATE A
REPLACEMENT TO BE CAL ACCESS
SYSTEM -- FOR FILING DISCLOSURES
IN CONTRIBUTIONS FOR ELECTIONS
ORIGINALLY THE IMPLEMENTATION
WAS SUPPOSED TO BE IN -- TWENTY
TWENTY IT TURNS OUT THIS WOULD
BE IN THE MIDST OF A NINETY DAY
ELECTION CYCLE REPORTING PERIOD --
AND THIS -- DEADLINE WAS SET
BEFORE CALIFORNIA MOVED UP IT'S
TWENTY TWENTY PRIMARY FROM JUNE
TO MARCH SO THIS WITH THE WAY
THAT DATE OUT IMPLEMENTATION TO
FEBRUARY OF TWENTY TWENTY ONE
AFTER NEXT YEAR'S ELECTION.
AND ALSO APPROPRIATE ABOUT SIX
POINT NINE MILLION DOLLARS FOR
IMPLEMENTATION.
THANK YOU QUESTIONS.
THE MORE LOCK.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AFTER THE
MOTOR VOTER.
AND WHAT WHAT I PUT ON ON IT
JUST THE AWKWARDNESS OF HOW IT
ALL ROLLED OUT PREMATURELY --
IRA I I WANT TO AFFIRM DELAYING --
THIS NEXT MOVES SO ALL THE I'M
OF THE ITEM THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS.
PUBLIC COMMENT.
SEEING NONE WE HAVE A MOTION
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL AB AT FOR
THE MOTION IS TO PASS MITCHELL
AYE MITCHELL AYE NIELSEN.
NIELSEN AYE BELL WELL I AFTER
ALSO [inaudible]
HER DAUGHTER.
JONES JONES I LEYVA.
MCGUIRE BEFORE I MONEY.
MORE LOCK MORE LIKE ONLINE
MORALE.
MORRELL AYE PAN [inaudible]
ROTH.
HI SKINNER SKINNER ONLINE STERN
[inaudible]
STONE.
STONE I AM BURKE.
AMBER GUY WHAT KASKI BECAUSE THE
HI.
WITH A VOTE OF TWELVE TO ZERO
THAT MEASURE KERRY'S
[inaudible]
ITEM.
SIX AB EIGHTY FIVE RESOURCES.
SAID THEIR NUMBER OF ITEMS IN
THIS BILL ALL MENTION BRIEFLY
THREE OF THAT -- FIRST IS. ONE
OF THE CAL FIRE INFRASTRUCTURE
PROJECTS REVOLVING FUND -- AND
THIS TRAILER BILL ALSO REQUIRES
CAL FIRE TO COORDINATE WITH THE
STATE WATER RESOURCES CONTROL
BOARD AND DEPARTMENT OF FISH
WILDLIFE ON TO REJECT FUEL
REDUCTION EFFORTS.
A SECOND IS CHANGES
INEFFICIENCIES O THE OFFICE OF
THE STATE FIRE MARSHAL FIRE LIFE
SAFETY HELPING TO CLARIFY THEIR
MISSION AND RESPONSIBILITIES --
AND THEN THIRD AT IN THE AREA OF
TWO G. R. F. POLLUTION REDUCTION
ALIGNING THE STATE'S EFFORTS
WITH COMMUNITY EFFORTS -- SAID
THESE ARE JUST THREE OF THE
ITEMS BUT HAPPY TO TAKE
QUESTIONS ON ANY OF THEM THANK
YOU QUESTIONS MEMBERS MISTER
MOORE LOCK. FOR JUST A QUESTION
OF WHO WILL SERVING ON THE
SELECT COMMITTEE ON WILDFIRES
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT SETTING UP A
FUND IS THAT COVERED AT ALL. FOR
VICTIMS AT ALL IN THIS BUDGET OR
IS THAT SOMETHING THAT WILL COME
LATER.
SO AT IN TERMS OF THE SBNINE A
ONE COMMISSION AND THE SOLUTIONS
THAT THEY'RE DISCUSSING THAT IS
NOT SPECIFICALLY IN THIS TRAILER
BILL OR OR PROCESS OUR BUDGET
PROCESS BUT THOSE CONVERSATIONS.
YOUR POINT ARE GOING ON RIGHT
NOW THANK YOU VERY MUCH THREE
NIELSEN.
SOME OF THESE PROVISIONS ARE
GOOD BUT TROUBLING TO ME IS
AGAIN THE EROSION.
OF THE LEGISLATORS AUTHORITY.
OVER CONTROLLING AGENCIES.
WE'RE A CALL [inaudible]
HERE. TO THE AIR RESOURCES BOARD.
MORE ABILITY TO CERTIFY.
COLLECTION OF CATION FEES
[inaudible]
AND IT'S BEYOND THE CONTROL THE
LEGISLATURE'S EVERY YEAR.
THE LEGISLATURE'S DOING MORE OF
THAT GIVING AS EXCEEDING THE
AUTHORITY OF THE LEGISLATORS AND
THE PEOPLE THEY REPRESENT TO THE
AGENCIES TO MAKE THEIR OWN
DETERMINATIONS.
OF THE APPLICATION OF FEES.
AND THE LATE A RATED FEES.
AND THEN THE ERR ERR BOARD IS TO
CREATE AN INDEPENDENT EMISSIONS
MARKET ADVISORY COMMITTEE.
I FEEL THAT THAT'S KIND OF A BAD
PRECEDENT SO THOSE NEGATIVE
FEATURES TO ME DISPOSE ME TO BE
A NO WELL.
THANK YOU ANY FURTHER QUESTIONS.
THREE NINE PUBLIC COMMENT. ONE
OF THE MEAT ON A WITHOUT AMONG
CALIFORNIA WE SUPPORT THIS A
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE EYES
SPECIFICALLY THE HABITAT
CONSERVATION FUND.
WE HOPE TO HAVE AN AYE VOTE
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS.
LYN COLLINS WITH THE MOUNTAIN
LION FOUNDATION HERE TO SUPPORT
THIS -- TRAILER BILL AND ALSO --
TO FOCUSED.
ON IMPORTANT SET OF DATA DOT
CONSERVATION FUND.
WHICH IS PRESERVED MORE THAN A
MILLION ACRES OF LAND FOR
HABITAT.
OVER THE LAST THIRTY YEARS THIS
IS AS FISCALLY RESPONSIBLE WAY.
TO ACQUIRE LAND AND MUCH OF IT
GOES NOT ONLY FOR ACQUISITION
BUT ALSO FOR PUBLIC ACCESS THANK
YOU SO MUCH.
AND ONLY SEVERAL -- DEFENDERS OF
WILDLIFE ALSO AS PART OF THIS
TRAILER BILL SPECIFICALLY THE
HABITAT CONSERVATION FUND THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU LETTER TO THE MOTION.
THANK YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
SB EIGHTY FIVE THE MOTION IS TO
PASS MITCHELL BY THE CHILL I
NIELSEN NO BILL NIELSEN NOBEL.
WELL I ALSO [inaudible]
THE OTHER.
JONES JONES NO LABOR.
MCGUIRE MCGUIRE AYE MONNING
[inaudible]
MORE LOCK.
MORE LOOK NO MORAL.
MORAL NO PAN [inaudible]
ROTH.
ROTH AYE SKINNER AYE SKINNER AYE
STERN.
STONE STONE NO -- BURKE.
NUMBER I WHY BECAUSE BECAUSE HE
I SEVEN THE FIVE WILL HOLD THAT
ITEM OPEN -- FILE ITEM NUMBER
SEVEN A. B. EIGHTY SEVEN
TRANSPORTATION [inaudible]
FINANCE. THREE POINTS ON EIGHTY
EIGHTY SEVEN FIRST THIS TRAILER
BILL -- REPAYS OUTSTANDING
TRANSPORTATION LOANS OF OVER ONE
BILLION DOLLARS -- THIS IS PART
OF THE BUDGETARY DEBT THAT THE
GOVERNOR REFERENCED IN JANUARY
IN PRESENTING HIS INITIAL BUDGET
A SECOND POINT THAT THIS BILL
MAKES A STRENGTHENING BE
CALTRANS INDEPENDENT OFFICE OF
AUDITS AND INVESTIGATIONS.
AND MAKING SURE THAT INFORMATION
PROVIDE WITH THEM WE ARE
STRENGTHENING CONFIDENTIALITY
PROTECTIONS -- THAT WAS
ESTABLISHED TWO YEARS AGO IN SB --
ONE AND WE WANT TO ABSTRACT AND
IT THROUGH THIS BILL -- AND THEN
THE THIRD IS THROUGH THE
CALIFORNIA TRANSPORTATION
COMMISSION -- ESTABLISHING
STATEWIDE COMPETITIVE GRANT
PROGRAM FOR SHORTLINE RAIL
PROJECTS.
THANK YOU QUESTIONS MEMBERS.
THIRTY NIELSEN YES I'M DISPOSED
TO BE A YES VOTE ON THIS BUT
I'LL MAKE A NOTE. ONE OF THE
PROVISIONS
OF TITLE TRANSPORTATION LOANS
FROM THE GENERAL FUND.
AND IT REVISES THE AMOUNT OF
TRANSPORTATION LOAN REPAYMENTS.
THE WOULD BE REPAIRED FOR SALUTE
TO THE RAINY DAY FUND.
AND THAT WAS A MAJOR ELEMENT OF
THE THE PROPOSITION.
TO THE SHIFTING OF THIS TWO
HUNDRED AND THIRTY SIX MILLION
DOLLARS TO OTHER GENERAL FUND.
AND THE RATIONALE IS TO ALLOW
THE APPLCATION TO PAY.
PENSION DEBT NOW THAT'S A GOOD
PURPOSE OKAY.
BUT TO DANGEROUS HAPPEN.
SO I HAVE TO RAISE CONCERN ABOUT
THAT.
THE REST OF IT I'LL BE OKAY
THANK YOU IN THE OTHER MEMBERS
HAVE QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
SEE NONE PUBLIC COMMENT.
IT WOULD MOVE PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL AB EIGHTY SEVEN THE MOTION
IS TO PASS MITCHELL.
BY JULY NIELSEN AYE NIELSEN AYE
BILL.
WELL I'D ARE ALSO -- ALSO I OR
THE OTHER.
JONES JONES NO LABOR.
LEYVA AYE MCGUIRE.
WHERE I MONEY MONEY NINE MORE
LOCK MORE LIKE ON A MORAL?
MORAL NO HAN.
ROTH.
ROTH AYE SKINNER.
SKINNER AYE STERN.
STONE STONE NO I'M BURKE.
NUMBER I BY BECAUSE HE BECAUSE
HE I YOU ARE.
ACTIVITY YOUR MAPS CAM.
THE VOTE OF TWELVE TO THREE THE
MEASURE KERRY'S.
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM.
EIGHT AB NINETY TWO SALES TAX
EXEMPTION AWAY FEAR CLEAN UP.
SO FOR BRIEF ITEMS OF NOTE IN
THIS -- BILL AB NINETY TWO THE
FIRST IS THE EXEMPTION -- FOR
DIAPER CHILDREN'S DIAPERS IN
FEMININE HYGIENE PRODUCTS ARE
FROM THE SALES AND USE TAX FOR
TWO YEARS THIS WOULD GO FROM
JANUARY FIRST.
TWENTY TWENTY THROUGH THE END OF
TWENTY TWENTY ONE AND THEN --
WITH THE SALES AND USE TAX
EXEMPTION THERE WOULD BE EVERY
BOARD REIMBURSEMENT FOR THE TWO
THOUSAND ELEVEN LOCAL REVENUE
FUND UNDER REALIGNMENT.
THE SECOND THING THIS BILL DOES
IT SAY CLARIFY SOME THE RULES
RELATED TO AB ONE FORTY SEVEN
WHICH THE LEGISLATURE ENACTED IN
THE GOVERNOR SIGNED EARLIER THIS
YEAR SPECIFICALLY RULES
GOVERNING THE DEFINITION OF A
MARKET PLACE FACILITATOR.
THE THIRD THING THAT THIS BILL
DIES IS A CAPS THE CD TFA LOOK
BACK PERIOD -- FOR SALES TAXES
ON SOME THESE RETAILERS THAT WE
DISCUSSED TO THREE YEARS SO
GOING BACK.
TO TWENTY SIXTEEN AND FINALLY
FOR THE TA THE OFFICE OF TAX
APPEALS THERE'S A STREAMLINING
MEASURE WHERE IF YOU'RE AN
INDIVIDUAL.
BUSINESS -- WITH A CASES
INVOLVING WESTON CERTAIN
THRESHOLDS THEN YOU DON'T HAVE
TO HAVE THE CASE DECIDED BY A
PANEL OF ADMINISTRATIVE LAW
JUDGES YOU COULD HAVE DECIDED BY
SINGLE JUDGE.
THANK YOU QUESTIONS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
ANY PUBLIC COMMENT.
THE IT BILLS WOULD MOVE PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL AB NINETY TO THE
MOTION IS TO PASS MITCHELL HI I
NIELSEN AYE NIELSEN AYE BELL.
THE OUTSIDE -- ALSO -- ALSO I OR
DAHLE THOUGH.
WHAT ARE THE AYE JONES JONES I
LABOR THEY'VE I'D MCGUIRE
MCGUIRE AYE MONEY MONEY NINE
MORE LOCK?
MORRELL.
MORRELL AYE PAN.
ROTH.
ROTH AYE SKINNER SKINNER AYE
STERN.
STONE STONE I NUMBER.
NUMBER GUY BECAUSE HE BECAUSE HE
I WITH A VOTE.
OF FIFTEENTH ZERO THE MEASURE
KERRY'S.
MOVING ON COLLEAGUES ITEM NINE
A. B. NINETY THREE THE BUDGET
ACT OF TWENTY EIGHTEEN TWO TWO
MAIN ITEMS IN THIS BILL -- THIS
IS A BILL REGARDING --
CORRECTIONS FUNDING AND IT IS
FOR THE CURRENT BUDGET YEAR --
THE CURRENT YEAR NOT THE BUDGET
YEAR SO FOR THIS IS FUNDING FOR
TWENTY EIGHTEEN NINETEEN AN
AUGMENTATION NOT FOR NINETEEN
TWENTY IT PROVIDES A HUNDRED
TWELVE POINT SIX MILLION FOR
NUMBER PURPOSES.
BUT NAMELY INVOLVING -- ACCESS
CONTRACT MEDICAL -- SPENDING AS
REQUIRED BY THE RECEIVER AS WELL
AS PHARMACEUTICAL COSTS AS WELL
AS OUR OUT OF STATE PRISON COSTS
AND I SHOULD NOTE -- IN
ANTICIPATION MANY QUESTIONS THAT
WE STILL BELIEVE THAT THE STATE
IS ON TRACK TO REMOVE ALL
INMATES FROM ITS ARIZONA
CORRECTIONAL FACILITY BY THE END
OF FISCAL YEAR.
TWENTY EIGHTEEN TWENTY NINETEEN
AND IN ADDITION TO THAT THIS
BILL INCLUDES A SMALL CLAIM TO
REIMBURSE MARIPOSA COUNTY FOR A
HOMICIDE CASE [inaudible]
QUESTIONS [inaudible]
PUBLIC COMMENT.
SEE NONE UNLIMITED EMOTION IT'S
BEEN MOVED PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
AB NINETY THREE THE MOTION IS TO
PASS MITCHELL HI ALL I NIELSEN
AYE AYE.
NIELSEN AYE BELL THE ONLINE --
ALSO DRAW SO I HEARD OTHER
[inaudible]
I JONES.
JONES I'D LEYVA.
LEYVA AYE MCGUIRE MCGUIRE AYE
MONEY MONEY NINE MORE LOOK.
MORE LIKE ON A MORAL
[inaudible]
I PAN [inaudible]
ROTH.
ROTH AYE SKINNER AYE SKINNER ON
STERN.
STONE STONE I AM BURKE.
NUMBER I Y. KASKI.
BECAUSE HE AYE [inaudible]
IT'S THE VOTE OF SIXTY TWO ZERO
THE MEASURE KERRY'S MOVING ON TO
FILE ITEM.
NUMBER TEN PUBLIC SAY WORK FOR
THAT TRANSFER -- SECOND ITEM OF
NOTE THIS BILL IS THE APPS THE
ARMS AND PREFER SINCE ARMED AND
PRIVATE PERSONS PROGRAMS WE HAD
A DISCUSSION LAST WEEK ABOUT
SOME OF THE BACKLOG AND THIS.
BILL PROVIDES SOME OF THE
REPORTING REQUIREMENTS IN TERMS
OF THE METRICS THAT WILL BE
PROVIDED BY THIRD WITH REGARDING
TO THAT THAT POST PROGRAM PIECE
OFF PEACE OFFICER STANDARDS AND
TRAINING -- THIS BILL REQUIRES
SOME TRAINING METRICS TO BE
PROVIDED BY THE COMMISSION -- SO
THAT WE'LL HAVE MORE INFORMATION
ABOUT WHERE THAT FUNDING IS
GOING AND THEN FINALLY THIS IS
STOP.
A RE ENTRY GRANT PROGRAM AND
PROVIDES FIVE MILLION DOLLARS IN
FUNDING.
THANK YOU QUESTIONS OF MEMBERS.
SEEING NONE PUBLIC COMMENT.
THE BILLS WOULD MOVE THANK YOU
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL AB NINETY
FOR THE MOTION IS TO PASS
MITCHELL HI I NIELSEN.
NIELSEN I AM BELL BILL I'D ARE
ALSO -- ALSO I WOULD OTHER.
OTHER I'D JONES JONES NO LEYVA
LEYVA AYE MCGUIRE.
MCGUIRE AYE MONNING MONEY NINE
MORE LOCK.
MORE LIKE I'D MORAL.
HELLO PAN.
NUMBER. EIGHTY SIX THANK YOU.
PAN.
ROTH.
AYE SKINNER SKINNER AYE STERN.
STONE.
STONE NO I'M BURKE.
NUMBER I WAY.
BECAUSE THE AYE.
THE VOTER THIRTEEN TO TO THE
MEASURE KERRY'S.
ITEM ELEVEN AB NINE FIVE NEW
JUDGESHIPS AT A COST OF THIRTY
POINT FOUR MILLION DOLLARS IN
THE BUDGET YEAR AND AS WE ALL
DISCUSSED OR AS MEMBERS THE
LEGISLATURE DISCUSSED AT THE
SHOULD BE ALLOCATED THROUGH A
NEEDS ASSESSMENT FROM THE
JUDICIAL COUNCIL.
AND SECOND THIS INCREASES THE
TRIAL COURT RESERVE CAP FROM 1%
23% THANK YOU QUESTIONS
[inaudible]
SENATOR ROBB.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR NOT SO
MUCH A QUESTION BUT TO A CONCERN
AND I MENTIONED THIS IN THIS
FORUM.
ON OTHER OCCASIONS BEFORE AND MY
CONCERN IS OVER.
REPORTS UNCONFIRMED OF COURSE
THAT THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL
INTENDS TO SEPARATE OUT THE
FUNDING ASSOCIATED WITH THE
SPECIFIC JUDGE.
POSITIONS FROM THE FUNDING.
THAT FOLLOWS NATURALLY FOR COURT
ROOM SUPPORT PERSONNEL AND
REALLOCATE THE COURT ROOM
PERSONNEL FUNDING.
IN A MANNER DIFFERENTLY THAN THE
NEEDS ASSESSMENT WOULD CALL FOR
THE TRIAL JUDGE POSITIONS TO BE
ALLOCATED.
IF TRUE THAT DEFEATS THE PURPOSE
FOR HAVING NEW JUDGESHIPS
BECAUSE YOU CAN'T HAVE A JUDGE
IN A COURT ROOM.
WITHOUT THE STAFF NECESSARY TO
OPERATE THE COR ROOM.
I HAVE ATTEMPTED.
TO GET SOME CONFIRMATION OF
EITHER POSITIVE OR NEGATIVE AS
TO THE ACCURACY OF THOSE REPORTS --
AN AS YET ALTHOUGH I'VE
MENTIONED IT IN THIS FORUM
BEFORE NO REAL INFORMATION IS
BEEN FORTHCOMING FROM THE
JUDICIAL COUNCIL AND I ASSUME
THEY LISTEN TO THESE PROCEEDINGS.
SO I'M OBVIOUSLY GOING TO VOTE.
FOR THIS TODAY BUT BEING THE
PERSON WHO WAS CARRIED A JUDGE
BILL IN VIRTUALLY EVERY YEAR OF
THE NOW GOING ON SEVEN YEARS
THAT I'VE BEEN UP HERE.
I WILL BE VERY DISAPPOINTED IF
THOSE REPORTS HAPPEN TO BE TRUE
AND I WOULD CERTAINLY HATE TO
HAVE TO OPPOSE THIS BILL.
ON THE FLOOR OF THIS HOUSE WHEN
IT COMES UP VERY VERY SOON SO.
TO THOSE OF YOU LISTENING OUT
THERE I WOULD APPRECIATE A PHONE
CALL TO LET ME KNOW THAT IN FACT
THOSE REPORTS ARE SIMPLY
INACCURATE.
AND THAT THE SUPPORT PERSONNEL
FUNDING WILL FOLLOW THE TRIAL
JUDGE FUNDING TO THE COURTS AS
DETERMINED.
BY THE NEEDS ASSESSMENT
[inaudible]
NO CRITICISM.
I APPRECIATE THE JUDGES THANK
YOU MANAGER THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
DID YOU WANT TO RESPOND.
SURE AARON OUTDOORS WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE --
HOPEFULLY THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL
REACH OUT TO AND PROVIDE.
MORE CLARITY BOOK BUT IT IS MY
UNDERSTANDING THAT THE
ALLOCATION.
METHOD ALL.
THIS TO PROVIDE RESOURCES TO THE
DIFFERENT COURTS AROUND THE
STATE TAKES INTO ACCOUNT HE
NUMBER OF JUDGES.
AND SO THEREFORE -- WHEN THEY
THE COURTS THAT RECEIVE MORE
JUDGES HI GET THOSE JUDGES THE
ALL ON THE NATURAL BE PROVIDED
WITH MORE RESOURCES WHEN THE
COURT USES THEIR -- THAT SYSTEM
METHODOLOGY TO DISTRIBUTE OUR
SUPPORT STAFF WELL I CERTAINLY
HOPE THEY DO REACH OUT OF THE
REPORT INDICATES THAT THERE'S A
MEMORANDUM FLOATING.
AMONG THE JUDGES.
THAT DOES EXACTLY THE OPPOSITE
OF THAT.
SO WE'RE GONNA HAVE TO DRILL
DOWN PRETTY QUICKLY TO FIND OUT
THE ANSWER TO THIS BUT THANK YOU
FOR YOUR RESPONSE AROUND FOR
YOUR HELP ON THE ISSUE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ANY FURTHER QUESTIONS THE BILL
HAS BEEN MOVES WITHOUT PUBLIC
COMMENT.
ANY PUBLIC COMMENT ON THIS ITEM
SEEN SEEN NONE.
OF THEM THERE HAS BEEN A MOTION
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
AB NINETY FIVE THE MOTION IS THE
PAST MITCHELL HI I NIELSEN.
NIELSEN I FELL WELL I ALSO.
DRAW THE EYES OR DODDLE WHAT
OTHER AYE JONES JONES ONLINE
LEYVA.
LEYVA AYE MCGUIRE MCGUIRE AYE
MONNING.
MONEY NINE MORLOCK.
WELL.
I PAN.
ROTH AYE SKINNER SKINNER AYE
STERN STONE.
STONE I AMBER.
AMBER GUY WHY BECAUSE HE BECAUSE
HE AYE.
THANK YOU ONE OF THE SIXTEEN
ZERO THE MEASURE KERRY'S ITEM
TWELVE A. B. NINETY SIX
EMERGENCY TELEPHONE USERS
SURCHARGE JACK FINANCE.
SO THIS BILL -- IMPLEMENTS THE
PROPOSAL OUT THAT WAS WE'VE BEEN
DISCUSSING -- SINCE THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET IN JANUARY
REGARDING THAT DECLINING BALANCE
AND SATIN AND STATE EMERGENCY
TELEPHONE NUMBER ACCOUNT -- THIS --
IS NECESSARY FOR IMPROVEMENTS TO
OUR NINE ONE ONE SYSTEM WHICH WE
KNOW IS OUTDATED AND THAT'S COME
UNDER STRESS SO THIS IS INVOLVED
IN CREATING REDUNDANCIES IN THE
SYSTEM MAKING SURE THAT THERE
AREN'T OUTAGES AND MAKING SURE
THAT CALLS.
CAN BE RE DIRECTED WHEN A
SPECIFIC NINE ONE ONE DISPATCH
CENTER CAN NO LONGER BE REACHED --
SO WHAT THIS BILL DOES THE
REASON THE FUNDING AND THAT --
ACCOUNT HAS GONE DOWN IS BECAUSE
WE HAVE CHARGED A FEE ON
INTERSTATE VOICE CALLS AND AS
PEOPLE SHIFT FROM VOICE CALLS TO
TEXTING AND OTHER FORMS OF
COMMUNICATION.
THE FEE REVENUE HAS DECLINED SO
INSTEAD WHAT THIS BILL DOES IS
CREATES A FLAT PER ACT.
SAYS FIND FEE WAS A FEE ON
MOBILE -- TRANSACT -- PREPAID
MOBILE TRANSACTIONS -- TO
REPLENISH THE ACCOUNT AND THE
LINE OUR SYSTEM WITH THE VAST
MAJORITY OF OTHER STATES IN THE
UNITED STATES UNDER THIS TRAILER
BILL THE NEW FLAT RATE FEE WOULD
BE BETWEEN ZERO AND EIGHTY CENTS --
WERE AT ESTIMATING CURRENTLY
THAT AND AT NEXT MONTH'S IT'S
IMPLEMENTED NEXT YEAR WILL BE
AROUND THIRTY FOUR CENTS
ALTHOUGH THAT IS SUBJECT TO SOME
FLUCTUATION IN -- YES WOULD MAKE
THE DETERMINATION BASED
SPECIFICALLY ON THE PARAMETERS
AND THIS TRAILER BILL SO THOSE
ARE THE KEY OUTLINES AND HAPPY
TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS THANK
YOU QUESTIONS MEMBERS SENATOR.
MCGUIRE THANK YOU SO MUCH
MANAGER NO QUESTIONS BUT A BRIEF
COMMENT.
A BRIEF ONE THANK YOU SO MUCH.
LOOK.
THIS IS GONNA BE THE SECOND TIME
THAT THE LEGISLATURE POTENTIALLY
SEE SINCE ISSUE.
AND BEING HONEST ABOUT IT I
THINK IT'S TIME THAT WE ALL SET
ASIDE OUR POLITICS -- AND
FINALLY GET THIS FEE PASSED --
THERE ARE SOME OF THE CHAMBERS
THAT WILL SAY THAT WE NEED TO BE
ABLE TO CONTINUE MOVE FOR THE
ONE TIME TIMES WE GOT SIXTY
MILLION THE BUDGET TO KEEP THE
FUND HOLE AT THIS POINT -- AND
THERE'S NO OTHER STATE IN THIS
UNION.
THAT FINDS AND NINE ONE ONE
UPGRADE WITH ONE TIME FUNDS.
IT'S ALL CHARGED BE A SURCHARGE.
AND I REALLY BELIEVE.
I THINK MANY OF US TO BEEN
IMPACTED BY FIRES BELIEVE THAT
IT'S TIME THAT WE PUT THE
POLITICS ASIDE AND FIND THE
UPGRADE THE NINE ONE ONE SYSTEM.
THAT WE'VE KNOWN THIS IS COMMON
FOR GREATER PART OF A DECADE IN
JUST WANTED TO BE A CIVIC CENTER
THIS IS GONNA BE DISCUSSION --
TO BE DETERMINED HERE IN THE
COMING WEEKS AND I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT WE START HAVING THAT
CONVERSATION NOW ON THIS
IMPORTANT ISSUE I APPRECIATE USE
AND REQUIRING COULDN'T AGREE
WITH YOU MORE. THIRTY NIELSEN.
WELL I WILL REITERATE MY
COLLEAGUE DID THAT THIS IS BEEN
AROUND A LONG.
AND IT'S BEEN.
THE FRUSTRATING AND THE MANNER
IN WHICH IT IS BEEN PURSUIT.
AND I THINK IN NO SMALL MEASURE
BY THE MANNER WHICH HAVE BEEN
PURSUED HAS BEEN REJECTED.
UNTIL NOW.
AND NOW I AM CONCERNED.
THOUGH BECAUSE OF THE SITUATION
IN THE AREA THAT I REPRESENT TO
IT'S PRETTY TOUGH FOR ME TO SAY
NO.
BUT I THINK THAT THIS A LITTLE
BIT AGREED HERE.
WHEN THIS IS ALLOWING AN AGENCY
OF GOVERNMENT? TO CYCLE UP TO IS
MUCH IS EIGHTY CENTS.
RAISING THE NINE ONE ONE IF YOU
WANT TO CALL IT A FATE.
I EXPECTED A LITTLE QUICKLY
STARTED EIGHTY IT WON'T END
TODAY.
AND I DON'T REALLY LIKE GIVING.
AUTHORITIES THAT KIND OF
AUTHORITY.
I LOVE THE DEPARTMENT AND THEY
WORK VERY WELL WITH THIS THIS
YEAR.
BUT THIS ONE IS KIND OF A LITTLE
BIT OF A DECEPTIVE THING I THINK
TO THE CITIZENS.
WHEN THEY GET A TO GET THEIR
BILLS?
MAYBE THEY'LL REALIZE.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
[inaudible]
PUBLIC COMMENT.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
COURCELLES -- HERE ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA STATE SHERIFFS
ASSOCIATION -- IN VERY STRONG
SUPPORT OF THIS PROPOSAL AS WE
WERE LAST YEAR -- BE
ADMINISTRATION LEGISLATURE
WORKED VERY CLOSELY -- AND VERY
DILIGENTLY ON THIS ISSUE -- AS
SENATOR MCGUIRE HAS STATED --
THIS IS CRUCIAL FUNDING -- BUT
NEEDS TO BE LONG TERM
SUSTAINABLE -- THIS BRINGS A
MODICUM OF FAIRNESS I WOULD
ARGUE -- TO TWO CHARGES ACROSS
THE BOARD -- IRRESPECTIVE OF THE
NATURE IN WHICH YOU COMMUNICATE --
AND SO WE WOULD APPLAUD THE
ADMINISTRATION THE LEGISLATURE
FOR PUSHING THIS FORWARD AND AND
VERY RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL
THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS.
THAT'S A GOOD EVENT IN THE ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF BECAUSE OF COUNTY
IS I WOULD ECHO THE COMMENTS OF
THE STATE'S HARRIS AND I'M WITH
SUPPORT AFTER I ABOUT.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU JULIE MALINOWSKI BOBBY
HAVE THE FIRE DISTRICTS
ASSOCIATION.
IN A FIRE CHIEFS ASSOCIATION --
IN STRONG SUPPORT WILL TO SACK
OF THE PREVIOUS SUPPORT OF
COMMON THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS.
GEN MEMBERS JONATHON FELDMAN
CALIFORNIA POLICE CHIEFS
ASSOCIATION IN CONJUNCTION WITH
THE OTHER COMMENTS -- IT'S
DIFFICULT TO PLAN FOR THE NEXT
GENERATION OF NINE ON ONE
WITHOUT SUSTAINABLE ON GOING
FUNDING SO WE SUPPORT THIS
PROPOSAL ON ESCRIBIR THANK YOU.
MARGARET LATCHING ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA RETAILERS ASSOCIATION
WE HAD TO HAVE AN A QUESTION TO
RAISE ABOUT THIS -- AS THIS BILL
MOVES FORWARD -- WE CERTAINLY
SUPPORT NINE ONE ONE THE PREPAID
FEES THAT ARE INCLUDED IN THIS
SCHEME.
THERE'S A CURRENT BILL WHERE
RETAILERS COLLECT POINT OF SALE
FEES CURRENT LAW THAT IS SUN
SETTING -- IN THAT WE ARE ABLE
TO COLLECT AND ADMINISTRATIVE
FEE FOR THE COLLECTION AND
REMISSION OF THOSE FUNDS TO THE
STATE WE'D LIKE TO SEE THAT
CONTINUE AS THIS BILL MOVES
FORWARD AND AS THIS ISSUE MOVES
FORWARD.
BUT CERTAINLY UNDERSTAND THE
IMPORTANCE OF NINE ONE ONE THANK
YOU APPRECIATE THAT -- GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE RIGHT WE DO HERE ON
BEHALF OF YOUR CALIFORNIA CITIES
ALSO PENSION FOR MY COLLEAGUE
WITH THE WORLD COUNTY REPRESENTS
A CALIFORNIA -- IN STRONG IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL AND QUITE
FRIENDLY THINK IT'S IT'S OVERDUE
IN AND I THINK IT'S GOOD FOR THE
SUSTAINABLE LONG TERM --
AVAILABILITY OF NOT THE NINE ONE
ONE SYSTEM THANK YOU THANK YOU
AS TO WHY ANY FURTHER COMMENTS
OR QUESTIONS.
THE BILL'S BEEN MOVE PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL AB NINETY SIX THE
MOTION IS THE PAST MITCHELL HI.
NIELSEN.
NIELSEN ONLINE BILL BILL ITER
ALSO DRAWS ALL AYE O'DONNELL.
JONES JON SNOW LEYVA LEYVA AYE
MCGUIRE MCGUIRE AYE MONEY MONEY
NINE MORE LOOK.
MORE LIKE NO MORRELL MORRELL NO
HAN.
ROTH.
ROTH AYE SKINNER ART SKINNER AYE
STERN.
STONE STONE NO NUMBER.
BY KASKI ACOSTA HI.
NIELSEN ITEM NO.
NIELSEN I DON'T KNOW.
VOTE OF NINE TO FIVE THE MEASURE
KERRY'S.
MOVING ON TO ITEM THIRTEEN A. B.
NINETY SEVEN CANNABIS.
SO THIS TRAILER BILL -- IT TAKES
A NUMBER STEPS CANNABIS I'LL
JUST MENTION THREE AND HAPPY TO
TAKE ANY QUESTIONS FIRST IT
STRENGTHENING THE EQUITY BY A
GRANT PROGRAM THAT WAS
ESTABLISHED IN LAW LAST YEAR.
FIVE WHICH TAKES A NUMBER OF
STEPS BUT ONE OF THEM IS
AUTHORIZING THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE OF BUSINESS AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT ON BEHALF OF THE
BEER OF CABINET CANNABIS CONTROL
TO ADMINISTER PROVISIONS RELATED
TO THE PROGRAMS FOR THE REVIEW
AND GRANTING A FUNDING FOR
CANNABISEQUITY PROGRAMS.
A SECOND NOTICE CLARIFICATION OF
THE AUTHORIZATION FOR LICENSING
AUTHORITIES TO ISSUE CITATIONS
AND ADMINISTRATIVE FINES FOR ANY
VIOLATIONS -- AND THIRTIES
EXTENSION OF THE REPEAL DATE FOR
PROVISIONAL LICENSING PROVISIONS.
AS WELL AS INCLUDING EXTENSION
NOT SICK WORDS ACTION TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE'RE BALANCING THE
NEED -- TO BRING -- OPERATORS
INTO THE LEGAL SYSTEM WITH THE
NEED FOR ENVIRONMENTAL
PROTECTION OVER THE NEXT COUPLE
OF YEARS.
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS THIRD TO
WHITE HOUSE FEE.
THE FEE FOR UNLICENSED PERSONS
PER VIOLATION PER DAY IS THIRTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS HOW DID YOU
LAND ON THAT NUMBER. THIRTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS PER DAY I'LL
HAVE TO GET BACK TO YOU
PRECISELY I BELIEVE THERE'S
SOMETHING ALREADY IN LAW FOR
EXISTING LICENSEES AND IT MAY BE
IN RELATION TO SERVE THE BANKING
AREA BUT I'LL GET BACK TO YOU ON
PERCENT ON THE PRECISE ANSWER.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS [inaudible]
THIRTY NIELSEN.
DOES THIS ALLOW THE IN TERMS OF
THE CANNABIS OF THE
CIRCUMVENTION OF THE
ADMINISTRATIVE PROCEDURES ACT.
THAT THEY DO NOT HAVE TO GO TO
THE ADMINISTRATIVE PROCEDURES
ACT REGULATORY AUTHORITY.
SO -- AS IT RELATES TO THAT
CANNABIS EQUITY GRANTED DOES
HAVE AN ALLOWANCE FOR TWO YEARS --
TO USE GUIDELINES VERSUS THE
REGULATORY PROCESS THAT WILL
ALLOW FOR THE FUNDS TO GO OUT
SOONER.
AND ALLOW THE GOBIZ SOMETIME AND
THE BUREAU CAN MISS CONTROLS AND
TIME TO DEVELOP A PROGRAM BEFORE
AND THEN FORMALIZED THOSE IN
REGULATIONS IN FUTURE YEARS.
WHAT DOES THAT MEAN THAT THIS?
FOR CONVENTION IS ONLY TEMPORARY
THAT THEY HAVE TO COME BACK
AGAIN AND GO THROUGH THE FULL
ADMINISTRATIVE HEARING PROCESS
YES LATER.
OKAY.
THAT MAKES A DIFFERENCE.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS.
I'LL ENTERTAIN ABOUT SENATOR
MCGUIRE WILL BE LESS THAN SIXTY
SECONDS AT FINE THANK YOU SO
MUCH.
THIS IS JUST IN REGARDS TO THE
ORGANIC PROGRAM WE HAVE TO
AGENCIES WHO ARE.
PROGRAM FOR THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
WE HAVE A FOOD NAG AS WELL AS AN
APARTMENT A PUBLIC HEALTH -- SB
NINETY FOUR TRAILER BILL BACK IN
TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN THERE IS
A DRAFTING ERROR.
BY THE LEFT OUT THE DEPARTMENT
OF PUBLIC HEALTH -- IN REGARDS
TO THE DRAFTING OF ORGANICS
LANGUAGE.
WE'VE BEEN WORKING WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH
BECAUSE YOU NEED BOTH AGENCIES
TO BE ABLE TO SIGN OFF ON THE
ORGANICS LANGUAGE.
WHAT WE'RE BEING TOLD NOW BY THE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH IS
THEY'RE GONNA PUT OFF?
AT THEIR PORTION OR THEIR AGAIN
X. LANGUAGE UNTIL.
TWENTY TWENTY TWO EVEN THOUGH WE
HAVE FOOD NAG ON A MUCH EARLIER
AT THE TIME FRAME. TO THERE'S
BEEN A LOT.
CANDIDLY SOME FRUSTRATION WITH
APARTMENT PUBLIC HEALTH WHO'S
NOT TAKE RESPONSIBILITY FOR WHAT
DISTRACTING HERE WAS -- IN THEY
KNOW THAT THERE'S A REQUIREMENTS
PROGRAM I JUST WANTED TO FLAG
THIS.
BECAUSE WE ARE INCONSISTENT WITH
FOOD NAG MOVING TO ONE LEVEL
PUBLIC HEALTH MOVE IN BEHIND
THEM -- AND WE HAVE THE
CONSUMERS ARE WAITING FOR US TO
GET OUR ACT TOGETHER AND
SOMETHING THAT WOULD LIKE TO GET
A LOOK AT CLEAN UP AS WE MOVE
FORWARD.
ANY RESPONSE FROM FINANCE --
THERE'S NOTHING IN THE TRAILER
BILL RELATED TO THIS ISSUE.
AND SOLD REQUIRE WILL BE
FOLLOWING UP WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION ON THIS ISSUE.
WITH THEM YES THANK YOU VERY
MUCH ANY OTHER QUESTIONS.
MISTER MOORE LOCK.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR JUST A
CLARIFICATION DOES THIS BILL
DEAL WITH THE CANNABIS LOCAL
EQUITY PROGRAM.
I DON'T SEE IT IN THE STAFF
REPORT.
BECAUSE YES IT DOES IT MAKE SOME
REFINEMENTS TO LAST YEAR'S --
SENATE BILL -- TWELVE NINETY
FOUR AND SORT OF STRENGTHENS THE
CONNECTION BETWEEN THE
POPULATION -- THAT HAVE A NEED
FOR THE SERVICE IS AND THOSE
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS AND MAKING
SURE THAT THE ONES THAT HAVE
MADE AN ASSESSMENT TO IDENTIFY
THOSE POPULATIONS ARE THE ONES
THAT WILL BE RECEIVE GRANT
FUNDING IN ADDITION TO MAKING
SOME OTHER CLARIFICATIONS AND
IMPROVEMENTS.
THANK YOU THANK YOU MANAGER.
DO YOU NEED ANY FURTHER
CLARIFICATION OF THE RESORT WAS
IN NINE YEARS GOT IT.
THANKS.
FOR LOOKING AT THE RIGHT GOT IT.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS SEEING NONE
PUBLIC COMMENT.
MADAM CHAIR WITH TAKING GREAT
LIBERTIES IS CHRISTY BOMB ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
PROFESSIONAL FIREFIGHTERS WHO
DID NOT RUN UP THE FERRET STAIRS
FAST ENOUGH.
WE'RE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB
NINETY SIX THANK YOU HOPE WE GET
CENTER NIELSEN BACK IN OTHERS A
VERY CRITICAL THANK YOU THANK
YOU.
BACK TO THE ISSUE OF CANDIDACY
SOLOMON SALAS WITH THE NATURE
CONSERVANCY WE WOULD JUST
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST THAT TO
YOUR BOND.
V. ALLOWANCE OF THE PROVISIONAL
LICENSES IN LIEU OF THE PROPOSED
FIVE YEARS WE FEEL THAT FIVE
YEARS IS TOO LONG AND WOOD AND
IT WOULD MAKE THE LEGISLATURE
SEATS MAJORITY -- WE SUBMITTED A
LETTER TO THE COMMITTEES THAT
AFFECT THEIR PARTNERS TRY TO
LIMITED AS WELL AS CAL TROUT
THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE HUBBARD
OF TRICKLE ME UP THE UNITED FOOD
AND COMMERCIAL WORKERS.
IN SUPPORT THE TRAILER BILL NOT
FOR COMMERCIAL WORKERS HAS BEEN
INVOLVED WITH THE CANNABIS
INDUSTRY BECAUSE WE WE SEE THE
OPPORTUNITY QUITE GOOD PAYING
JOBS.
THE EFFORTS IN THIS BILL NUMBER
ONE I LIKE TO TO FOR PARTS OF
THE OF THE BILL IN PARTICULAR
ONE THE SOCIAL EQUITY OF
RECOMMITMENT TO SOCIAL EQUITY
WHICH IS.
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT SECOND THE
RECOMMEND AND THE FUNDING FOR
MORE ENFORCEMENT.
ON LICENSE OPERATORS
UNDERCUTTING ABILITY OF LICENSE
OPERATORS BECAUSE THEY BECAUSE
SO MUCH LESS EXPENSIVE AND
OPERATE WITHOUT DOING GOING TO
LESSEN PROCESS IN A TESTING
PROSELYTE SO WE SUPPORT.
THE BILL THE DOOR.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS ROBERT
HARRIS ON BEHALF YEAH SO YEAH
YOU CALIFORNIA WE'RE IN TOTAL
SUPPORTED THE EQUITY PROGRAM AND
WE LIKED THAT FINDS ON THE
UNLICENSED.
OPERATORS WHO ARE MANY OF THE
THINGS ARE PUTTING OUT THERE ARE
ARE A FULL A PESTICIDE THAT IRAN
TESTED AND AS A MATTER OF FACT
OUR LA PEOPLE.
ARE IN CHARGE.
MAKE SURE THAT THE PROGRAM RUNS
RIGHT AND THIS HELPS US DO THAT
THANK YOU.
MARIN PEANUT ON BEHALF OF THE
UNITED CANNABIS BUSINESS
ASSOCIATION THE SAN CANO'S
BUSINESS ASSOCIATION.
THE LONG BEACH COLLECTIVE
CANNABIS ASSOCIATION THE UNITED
MEDICAL MARIJUANA COALITION OUT
OF SAN DIEGO.
THE SAN FRANCISCO CANNABIS
RETAILERS ALLIANCE -- THE
COACHELLA VALLEY CANNABIS
ALLIANCE NETWORK.
WE STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL
WE'VE SEEN.
IT LEGAL DISPENSARIES OP POP UP
EVERYWHERE AND THAT OVER AT OVER
HOW HUNDREDS I WOULD SAY
THOUSANDS WE SEEN DEATHS AT SOME
OF THIS DISPENSARIES WE SEEN
PEOPLE GET SICK.
WE SEE LOCAL GOVERNMENTS NOT
COLLECT THE REVENUE THEY NEED
OUT THAT THIS IS THE FIRST STEP
IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION. TO
ENSURE THAT WE GET THE SYSTEM UP
AND RUNNING AND WE THINK THAT
COMMITTEE AND ADMINISTRATION FOR
PUTTING THIS [inaudible]
FOR THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIRWOMAN
COMMITTEE MEMBERS AMY JENKINS ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
CANNABIS INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION --
WE WANT TO ECHO THE PREVIOUS
COMMENTS MADE BY MY COLLEAGUE
AND WE HAVE BEEN VERY VERY
CONCERNED ABOUT THE ILLICIT
MARKET AND THE INCREASE IN THE
ILLICIT MARKET SO WE DO
APPRECIATE.
THE ADDITIONAL PENALTY.
LIST ON UNLICENSED OPERATORS AND
HOPEFULLY THAT WILL BE A
DETERRENT TO UNLAWFUL ACTIVITY
WE FURTHER ONCE.
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THE
PROVISIONAL LICENSE LANGUAGE AND
REMOVING THE A TEMPORARY LICENSE
REQUIREMENTS AND ALSO EXTENDING
THAT PROGRAM THAT IS CRITICALLY
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT FOR THIS
INDUSTRY -- AND I ALSO WANT TO
NOTE -- SENATOR REQUIRES
LEADERSHIP ON THAT PARTICULAR
ISSUE AS WELL HE'S BEEN A REAL
CHAMPION ON THAT UNLESS THE WE
SUPPORT THE EQUITY PROVISIONS IN
THE BILL -- AN ADDITION TO THE
THE AUGMENTATION OF FUNDS -- AS
OF THIS IS A GOOD STEP FORWARD
AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING TO WORK WITH YOU
THANK YOU FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS THURMOND
TSUNAMI HAVE A THE CALIFORNIA
STATE ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES
HERE IN SUPPORT OF THIS MEASURE
IT PROVIDES LOCAL GOVERNMENTS.
THE TOOLS AND THE TIME NECESSARY
TO PROCESS THE NUMBER OF
APPLICATIONS THAT WE'RE DEALING
WITH THAT THE LOCAL LEVEL
INCLUDING THE ENVIRONMENTAL
REVIEW PROCESS AND WE URGE YOUR
SUPPORT OF THING.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS.
CHAIR AND MEMBERS I'M TRACY
STEVENS REPRESENTING NOR CAL
CANNABIS I TOO WANT TO THANK YOU
AND YOUR STAFF FOR THE
TREMENDOUS WORK ON THIS TRAILER
BILL.
WE SPECIFICALLY ARE VERY
SUPPORTIVE OF THE PROVISIONAL
LANGUAGE CHANGES ON THE EQUITY
PROGRAM EXPANSION THANK YOU.
I'VE AFTER HOLD FOR ME TARGET TO
THE FLAT BILLS.
BRAND MAR NOT BE ON BEHALF OF
COOLEY THE WHICH IS BASED IN SAN
JOSE IN VERY STRONG SUPPORT
ESPECIALLY ON THE ISSUES
RELATIVE TO THE EXTENSION AND
STRENGTHENING OF THE PROVISIONAL
LICENSE PIECE.
ON THE EQUITY LANGUAGE AND MOST
IMPORTANTLY THE ADDITIONAL --
FINDS ON ILLICIT OPERATOR IS
VERY IMPORTANT TO GET THE SIDE
THIS INDUSTRY STABILIZE THANK
YOU.
I'LL ENTERTAIN A MOTION.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL AB NINETY
SEVEN THE MOTION IS TO PASS
MITCHELL AYE MITCHELL AYE
NIELSEN.
BILLS A NOBEL.
THE EYES ARE ALSO.
DRAWS AYE O'DONNELL WOULD OTHER
I'D JONES.
LEYVA.
LEYVA AYE MCGUIRE THE CAR I
MONEY.
I MEAN I'M MORE LUCK MORRELL
MORRELL NO PAN.
ROTH BROUGHT BY SKINNER.
STERN.
SKINNER AYE STERN STONE.
STONE NO AMBER.
AMBER GUY WAY BECAUSE HE BECAUSE
HE AYE.
HELLO VOTE ELEVEN TO THREE THE
MEASURE.
KERRY'S OUR LAST ITEM COLLEAGUES
AND WE HAVE THREE ITEMS I THINK
THAT ARE ON CALL. THIRTEEN AB
ONE OH FOR CORRECTIONS
FACILITIES FINANCING
[inaudible]
FINANCE.
ONLY ONE MAJOR HIGHLIGHT HERE
THIS IS THIS BILL PROVIDES FORTY
NINE POINT NINE MILLION DOLLARS
IN LEASE REVENUE BONDS AUTHORITY
FOR CONSTRUCTION FOR REMAINING
EXCEPT PROJECTS HECTIC STANDS
FOR HEALTH CARE FACILITIES
IMPROVEMENT PROGRAMS.
AND SO THESE ARE FACILITIES THAT
WITHIN CDC ARE TO PROVIDE AN
ADEQUATE LEVEL OF MEDICAL CARE
[inaudible]
QUESTIONS.
THE BILL HAS BEEN MOVE UP ANY
PUBLIC COMMENT.
ON EIGHTY ONE OH FOUR SEEN NONE
WE HAVE A MOTION PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL IF YOU WANT TO FOR THE
MOTION IS TO PASS MITCHELL HI.
I NIELSEN.
I NIELSEN AYE BELL.
WELL I ALSO -- ALSO I HOOKED
ALTHOUGH WHAT OTHER AYE JONES
LEYVA.
LEYVA AYE MCGUIRE [inaudible]
MONNING.
FUNNY NEY MORLOCK MORRELL.
PEARL NO PAN.
ROTH AYE SKINNER.
SKINNER AYE STERN.
STONE -- BURKE.
RIGHT NUMBER I Y. KASKI BECAUSE
HE AYE.
THE WORLD'S FIRST.
TO SURE THANK YOU VERY MUCH
[inaudible]
YEAH [inaudible] ELEVEN ONE
YOU'RE INSISTING [inaudible]
OKAY GREAT.
I'M I'VE BEEN ASKED TO OPEN THE
ROLE IN THE FIRST.
TWO GOOD TO MY COLLEAGUES ON THE
OTHER SIDE OF THE AISLE
[inaudible]
A FAVOR.
PLEASE OPEN AB SEVENTY SEVEN
HIGHER EDUCATION CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS ARE ALL [inaudible]
FIFTEEN TO FIFTEEN TO TO THE
MEASURE KERRY'S WE'RE GONNA OPEN
THE ROLE ON THREE ADDITIONAL
ITEMS A. B..
EIGHTY THREE PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS ARE ALSO -- ALSO
AYE O'DONNELL PATEL I LEYVA
LEYVA AYE MONEY.
MONEY I PAN.
STERN.
STERN HI [inaudible]
WELL MIKE. TWELVE TO FIVE THE
MEASURE.
KERRY'S WE'RE GONNA OPEN THE
ROLE ON ITEM SIX A. B. EIGHTY
FIVE RESOURCES PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS.
ARE AWESOME DRESS SO I WOULD
TELL THEM THE TOTAL AYE LEYVA.
LEYVA AYE MONEY MONEY I PAN
STERN STERN HI. TWELVE TO FIVE
THE MEASURE CARE IS WE'RE GONNA
OPEN THE ROLE ON THE FINAL ITEM
ITEM TWELVE A. B..
NINETY SIX EMERGENCY TELEPHONE
USERS SURCHARGE ACT PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS WITH OTHER
[inaudible]
PAN.
STERN.
STERN I BURKE.
BUT IF TEND TO FIVE THAT MEASURE
KERRY'S.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH COLLEAGUES
SENATE BUDGET STANDS ADJOURNED